what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time but
while she's trying to get rich dresses
trying to get her lunch money right i'm
here with polina i don't know what she's
wearing looks a little bit like an
animal
but i'm not gonna say anything about it
he ain't gonna say anything about it not
gonna say anything about it don't forget
that lunch money is now sponsored by
block [ __ ]
cue the music block clock.com
you can go to blockclock.com
okay don't forget that you can go get a
interest bearing account
you can buy and sell crypto on the
crypto exchange or you can deposit
crypto and take out a us dollar alone
against your crypto collateral go get an
account block five dot com slash pomp
block five dot com slash pomp what's up
goldman sachs on tuesday beat
analysts expectations for fourth quarter
profit and revenue on strong performance
from the firm's
equities traders and investment bankers
why could the banks all be making so
much money
i wonder why maybe the banks realized
that the government was just going to
print a bunch of money asset prices were
going to explode
and if they were long assets they would
make a lot of money
it shouldn't be shocking that the banks
are making a lot of money just
go ahead david solomon said we were able
to keep
but sorry we were able to help clients
navigate a difficult environment and as
a result achieve strong results across
the franchise
while advancing our strategic priorities
so they were helping they were able to
help their clients
be long assets sure
by the way bank of america uh also
turned to profit a bunch of these guys
so it's not just goldman sachs goldman
sachs had
records but the other ones all did
pretty well for themselves too
don't expect that to change anytime soon
from the banks
ether is closing in on an all-time high
the cryptocurrency
one of many alternatives to bitcoin
rallied as much as 17
on tuesday to an intraday high of 1
439 dollars i put this in here just so
everyone's clear i put this
did the topics today i put this one in
here so i'm tired of y'all telling me
who i am and what i am and what i
believe all i'm gonna say is
the reason why i put this in here is
ethereum which is
uh the network ether which is the
currency hit an all-time high
congratulations to all of you that held
through the entire bear market
or if you dollar cost average to the
bear market it feels great to hit an
all-time high
i can recognize when somebody went
through a lot of pain
and they get rewarded good job it hit an
all-time high congratulations
okay let's move on
biden will lift your brazil travel
restrictions despite trump order
spokeswoman
says biden's see this is so hard when he
does the topics because i have no idea
what i'm reading
biden's transition team said it won't
lift the travel restrictions
after trump leaves office and when u.s
bound travelers will need to show a
negative covet test
before flying uh joe biden is racist
joe biden is racist but trump had banned
most foreign visitors from europe and
result early in the pandemic to curb the
spread of the virus
by the way i don't think either one of
them uh should be labeled as racist or
not racist based on travel bans because
of the virus
but that's how ridiculous we've gotten
to in the media is that
when the current president made travel
restrictions everyone yelled and
screamed and said racist
now the current president is trying to
undo the travel ban and allow people to
travel but the incoming president says
no we're gonna keep the travel
ban in place so either we decide that
putting travel bans in place is
targeting certain
uh people and that makes you racist or
we say that no
it's not racist but you can't treat two
different people
and by the way i don't i don't agree
with either one of these people
right i'm independent but you can't
treat one person one way and the other
the other way when it comes to the same
exact action
so the thing that we need in american
politics is real simple
we need less divisiveness and we need
more people to come together cohesion
come together come together find the
common ground
come together work together but this
whole idea of if two people do the same
thing and one person is labeled a racist
the other person is lauded for it that's
just divisiveness that's
solely centered around a two-party
political system and it's
garbage we have to come together we have
to treat people the same way if you do
something bad you should be called out
for it you do something good you should
be praised for it that's it
done it's easy stop being crazy you hit
an all-time high you should be called
out for it you get pregnant you get
praised for it oh sorry well same thing
that's what i meant
all right next um janet yellen us
president-elect
joe biden's nominee to run the treasury
department
will tell the senate finance committee
on tuesday that the government must
act big with its next coronavirus relief
package what does that mean it was
outlined in
1.9 trillion you guys should go
go to your living room kick back in the
recliner grab a bud light
and just chill out because for the next
four years
they're gonna print so much money
oh so they're going to just guys the
chronovirus relief and print
is about money right now i thought it
was like something else
no they're gonna print another 1.9
trillion dollars i thought it was giving
people some cough drop some
something no no they want to give people
2 000
a month that's what they want to give
them forget cough drops we'll give you
two thousand dollars a month
the reason why i put this in here is
janet yellen who is the former
head of the federal reserve is going to
become the treasury secretary
she's gonna go in front of the senate
finance committee and testify today
and what she's to basically say is hey
we need to get very serious
about preventing another market downturn
but these people have lost their minds
they're going to print money and print
money and print money and print money
they're going to devalue the dollar
and all you have to do to look like a
genius from an investing standpoint
which is the next topic which is educate
yourself
you just got to be long investable
assets
that's it this is how it works there's
dollars you get paid in dollars if you
hold
those dollars they are going to devalue
them meaning that it will take more
dollars in the future to buy
certain assets goods or services if you
sit in the dollars
you will become poorer you will lose
your purchasing power if when you get
paid dollars you either consume
goods and services or you invest the
money
you will protect yourself now
consumption means that money's going out
investing means that money's going out
but it's growing for you so if you're
smart what you will do is you will spend
less than you
make you will get out of debt you will
make sure that you've got multiple
streams of income
you will make sure that you're out of
cash and into investable assets and then
you'll chill out
you'll get a beer you sit in a recliner
you're still patient and disciplined
for a couple of years and you're going
to be just fine
so guess what stop trying to be smarter
than the market just do what rich people
do
rich people get paid they spend less
than they make they make sure that they
aren't in debt and cut like consumer
debt credit card debt all that kind of
stuff
and then they go and they invest go
invest your assets and the federal
reserve the treasury secretary and the
president united states
is going to make you rich they're going
to make you rich
if you have investable assets i don't
care what investable assets you have
gold real estate stocks bitcoin it's all
going to go up because they're going to
devalue the dollar so if you want joe
biden to make you rich if you want janet
yellen to make you rich if you want the
government to make you rich
go invest invest invest invest and
hold those assets for a long period of
time and they're going to devalue the
dollar and you're going to be rich
was that educate yourself was that last
time yeah that hey by the way
that was an economics 101 course just so
we're all clear
ain't no school gonna tell you all that
what they're gonna tell you is all is
garbage
that was a real real quick education
what t-shirt are we wearing
today oh yeah yeah yeah
no free ads on this podcast or video or
whatever it is i ain't doing no more
read the profile.com guys got my dad and
my mom calling me telling me pump boys
motors needs more air time no it doesn't
yesterday was enough all right what's up
with ask lunch okay
so yesterday's ask lunch money was
surprisingly alien focused
we got steve ruiz asking love what y'all
guys
do y'all guys oh that's bold steve um my
question is have you ever seen a ufo
before or something eerie in the sky
so i actually have a story when i was
like
nine i was um out playing with my
friends
because you know we used to play outside
and i saw something in the night sky
and it was these like lights and i was
like that's that's gotta be a ufo like
what else could it be
and it was just like in a large circle
and i went home and i asked my mom and
she was like
um there's a club down the street
and they have those like projection
things
that you know project to light so you
know where it is i was like god
what did i think of that uh i only have
one story uh i live with an alien
excuse me i've never seen the ufo but
they real
they real they are okay go ahead
the most lovely alien he's ever met
nisami if an alien beamed down in front
of you right now and somehow asked you
in plain english
where am i what would you answer i'd be
like listen
i booked this airbnb not thinking it
would be like this
but you're here too right now you wanna
know what i would say
oh my god i don't know what home jesus
i just say you're home come hang out
with me
ryan har meyer wait this
i mean what is up with all of the aliens
no this is the one
this touched my heart pimp the tomato
plant make the trip with you to miami if
not i think we need to hold a moment of
silence
to pay our respects we do ryan we do
need to hold a moment of silence you
know why
no talking for a minute no well just you
know you can do it at home
but you know what i've already done my
silence you know why
because i took care of it i ate the
fruits of
its labor you know you even from your
labor
well of its labor you ate the fruits of
its labor these little tiny
tomatoes they were so good right they
were amazing it did all it could for me
and then where did we go oh for
for the holidays we were gone and it
wasn't it was alone and i came back to
a water scene it died a crime scene
i did not kill it i watered it plenty
before
anyway i'm a horrible plant mom this is
truly terrible
thank you for reminding me yeah
but but i will do better in the future
okay so sad see you guys tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest
on an interest-bearing account or you
can buy and sell cryptocurrencies on
their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends